>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THIS IS
JOE BIDEN’S THIRD ATTEMPT TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
HISTORY IS LOST WHEN YOU LIVE IN
THEINTHE ETERNAL PRESENT AS WE A
NOW.
THE FIRST TIME BIDEN RAN WAS IN
1988, THAT WAS BEFORE MOST OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK ON THE SHOW
WERE BORN AND HE WAS CAUGHT
LYING ABOUT HIS BIOGRAPHY AND
SPEECHES AND FORCED TO DROP OUT.
BIDEN SUGGESTED TO AUDIENCES
THAT HE HAD GROWN UP IN A COAL
MINING FAMILY IN WALES.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
JOE BIDEN IS ACTUALLY FROM
AMERICA, HIS FATHER SOLD CARS IN
WILMINGTON.
BIDEN WENT TO CATHOLIC PREP
SCHOOL IN THE SUBURBS.
IT TOOK 20 YEARS BEFORE BIDEN
RAN AGAIN AND WHEN HE DID, IT
DID NOT GO WELL.
IN 2008, JOE BIDEN GOT A TOTAL
OF 1% OF THE VOTE IN THE IOWA
CAUCUSES.
HE DROPPED OUT THAT NIGHT.
JOE BIDEN, WHATEVER HIS
STRENGTHS, TURNED OUT TO BE SO
BAD AT RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
THAT EVEN BARACK OBAMA,
SUPPOSEDLY HIS CLOSE FRIEND,
REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO ENDORSE
HIM.
"HE JUST CAN’T WIN," THAT WAS
BARACK OBAMA’S VIEW.
THEN THE WUHAN CORONAVIRUS
ARRIVED.
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS CHECKED ON
THE COUNTRY, MILLIONS LOST THEIR
JOBS, AMERICANS HUDDLED IN THEIR
HOMES, CUT OFF FROM ONE ANOTHER
AND DEEPLY MISERABLE.
FROM HIS BASEMENT, STRATEGICALLY
CLOISTERED AWAY IN SILENCE,
JOE BIDEN SHOT AHEAD IN THE
POLLS.
NOT BECAUSE OF ANYTHING HE DID,
HE JUST HAPPENS TO BE THERE.
AS OF TONIGHT, JOE BIDEN COULD
WIN THE RACE.
UNFORTUNATELY, IF HE DOES,
JOE BIDEN CANNOT GOVERN THE
COUNTRY.
HE HAS ALL BUT ADMITTED THAT, HE
SAID HE WON’T RUN FOR A SECOND
TERM.
SO BIDEN’S RUNNING MATE WILL BE
THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL VP PICK
IN AMERICAN HISTORY AND SOON WE
WILL KNOW WHO IT IS.
APPARENTLY THE ANNOUNCEMENT IS
COMING IN THE NEXT WEEK.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE FRONT RUNNER,
SHE CERTAINLY THE MOST
WELL-KNOWN.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THEY LOVE HER.
SHE’S ONE OF THEM.
THE PUBLIC, THOUGH, HAS BEEN
MUCH LESS IMPRESSED INCLUDING
DEMOCRATS.
HARRIS WAS SO UNPOPULAR WITH
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS THAT
SHE NEVER MADE IT TO THE FIRST
VOTE IN THE PRIMARY.
WHEN SHE DROPPED OUT IN
DECEMBER, HARRIS WAS PULLING
AROUND 3%.
THE WRAP AND EXIT POLLS IS THAT
SHE’S A FRAUD, SHE DOESN’T
REALLY BELIEVE IN ANYTHING AND
SHE WILL SAY WHATEVER IT TAKES.
THAT IS ALSO HARRIS’ PRIMARY
STRENGTH.
HERE SHE IS PROMISING FREE
HEALTH CARE TO ILLEGAL ALIENS.
>> SO YOU SUPPORT GIVING
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE, MEDICARE
FOR ALL TO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY?
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS, I AM OPPOSED TO ANY POLICY
THAT WOULD DENY IN OUR COUNTRY
ANY HUMAN BEING FROM ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY, PUBLIC EDUCATION,
OR PUBLIC HEALTH, PERIOD.
>> Tucker: NOW WAIT A SECOND,
YOU MAY BE WONDERING.
I’M SITTING IN MY HOUSE, MAYBE
UNEMPLOYED, PAYING A HUGE
PERCENTAGE OF MY NET WORTH FOR
HEALTH CARE.
SO WHY SHOULD PEOPLE WHO AREN’T
EVEN ALLOWED TO BE IN THIS
COUNTRY IN THE FIRST PLACE GET
IT FOR FREE AT MY EXPENSE?
BY THE WAY, HOW CAN A GOVERNMENT
THAT’S ALREADY $27 TRILLION IN
DEBT AFFORD TO PAY FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD’S MEDICAL BILLS?
THOSE ARE ALL GOOD QUESTIONS.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS NO ANSWERS,
FIXING THE PROBLEM IS NOT THE
POINT OF THE EXERCISE.
WINNING IS THE POINT.
OVER THE YEARS, HARRIS HAS BEEN
WILLING TO DO PRETTY MUCH
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO WIN,
INCLUDING USE THE POWER OF HER
OFFICE TO CRUSH POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA, HARRIS RELENTLESSLY
DEFENDED HER BIG DONORS, WHEN A
JOURNALIST CRITICIZED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN A DOCUMENTARY,
KAMALA HARRIS SPENT THE POLICE
TO HIS HOME.
HE LATER DESCRIBED THE
AUTHORITARIAN NIGHTMARE HARRIS
UNLEASHED ON HIS LIFE.
>> THEY GOT A HIGHLY POLITICAL
SEARCH WARRANT TO CONDUCT A
POLITICAL RAID ON MY HOME
DISEASE THE UNDER COVERED
FOOTAGE, BLACK LETTER CALIFORNIA
LAW THAT YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
GET SEARCH WARRANT TO SEIZE THE
UNPUBLISHED MATERIALS OF A
JOURNALIST, CITIZEN JOURNALIST,
PROFESSIONAL JOURNALIST BUT
THAT’S WHAT KAMALA HARRIS WENT
AHEAD AND DID IN ORDER TO COVER
UP FOR THEM AND PROTECT THEM
FROM INCREASED FURTHER SCRUTINY
FOR THE CRIMES OF SELLING
ABORTED BABY BODY PARTS,
SOMETIMES FROM CRIMINAL
PARTIAL-BIRTH ABORTIONS.
>> Tucker: SO I THINK WHAT WE
CAN CONCLUDE FROM THIS EPISODE
IS THAT KAMALA HARRIS OR ANY
POLITICIAN WILLING TO USE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO STOP
JOURNALISM SHE DOESN’T LIKE
PROBABLY DOESN’T CARE TOO MUCH
ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES OR
EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW, AND
INDEED SHE DOESN’T.
HARRIS SUPPORTS ALLOWING
UNIVERSITIES TO HIRE AN EMPLOYER
BASED ON THE SKIN COLOR OF
APPLICANTS.
SHE’D LIKE TO REWRITE THE
CONSTITUTION TO ELIMINATE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE BECAUSE IT’S
INCONVENIENT.
JUST TEN YEARS AGO, BARACK OBAMA
WOULD’VE RUN AWAY FROM THEM,
THAT’S A MUCH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS CHANGED.
IF YOU’RE LOOKING FOR MORE
EVIDENCE OF THAT CHANGE, YOU
SHOULD ALSO KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
IS CONSIDERING CONGRESSWOMAN
KAREN BASS OF LOS ANGELES AS HIS
RUNNING MATE, SHE’S ALSO ON THE
SHORT LIST.
UNLIKE KAMALA HARRIS, KAREN BASS
IS NOT A FRAUD.
KAREN BASS MEANS IT.
SHE’S SINCERE.
AN UNAPOLOGETIC LEFT-WING BOMB
THROWER WHO SPENT DECADES
WORKING TO HELP FIDEL CASTRO AND
HIS COLD WAR AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES.
KAREN BASS KEPT PRAISING
FIDEL CASTRO ALL THE WAY TO HIS
DEATH FOUR YEARS AGO.
IN THE 1970s, KAREN BASS
BELONGS TO A GROUP THAT THE L.A.
POLICE DEPARTMENT ACCUSED OF
TREADING REVOLUTIONARIES IN
"TERRORIST TACTICS AND GUERRILLA
WARFARE."
BASS APPARENTLY VISITED CUBA
MULTIPLE TIMES A YEAR.
KAREN BASS IS NOT A MAINSTREAM
FIGURE.
SHE LITERALLY COSPONSOR TO THE
NEW WAY FORWARD ACT, THAT IS A
LUNATIC BILL THAT WOULD FORCE
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO RE-IMPORT
AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS THAT
WE’VE DEPORTED FOR COMMITTING
CRIMES.
IN MANY CASE, VIOLENT CRIMES,
FOR REAL.
KAREN BASS IS SO EXTREME THAT
LIKE KAMALA HARRIS, BY THE WAY,
SHE’S CURRENTLY TRYING TO REPEAL
CALIFORNIA’S MAIN
ANTIDISCRIMINATION LAW.
BASS WANTS TO MAKE RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION LEGAL AS IT WAS
BEFORE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
WE ARE NOT OVERSTATING THIS.
KAREN BASS HAS ISSUED PRESS
RELEASES BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
YOU MAY NOT OF HEARD ABOUT ANY
OF THIS, THE DETAILS ARE RUSHED
SO SHOCKING THAT VIRTUALLY NO
MEDIA OUTLET BOTHERS TO COVER
THEM BUT IT IS ALL REAL, LOOK IT
UP.